and there's no telling
what spooky things may in fact be true I
mean I don't know if you've been on the
receiving end of you know recent rumors
about uh
our conversation about UFOs is very
likely changing in the near term right
but like there was just a Washington
Post article and a New York article and
you know I've received some private
Outreach and perhaps you have I know
other people in our our orbit have
people who are claiming that the
government has known much more about
UFOs than they have led on until now
and this conversation is actually is
about to become more prominent you know
and it's it's not going to be
whatever you know whoever's left
standing When the Music Stops it's not
going to be a comfortable position to be
in as a you know super rigorous
scientific skeptic saying there's no
there who's been saying there's no there
there for the last 75 years right like
like uh the short version is it sounds
like
the Office of Naval intelligence and the
Pentagon are very likely to say to
Congress at some point in the not too
distant future that
we have evidence that there is
technology flying around here that seems
like it can't possibly possibly be of
human origin right now I don't know what
I'm going to do with that kind of
disclosure right maybe it's just it's
gonna it's gonna be nothing no
follow-on conversation you really have
but that is such a powerfully strange
circumstance to be in right I mean it's
just what are we going to do with that
if in fact that's what happens right
uh if in fact the the considered opinion
despite the the embarrassment it causes
them
of the U.S government of all of our
intelligence all the relevant
intelligence Services is that
this isn't a hoax it's too there's too
much data to suggest that it's a hoax
we've got too much radar imagery there's
too much too much satellite data
whatever data whatever data they
actually have there's too much of it
all we can say now is something's going
on and
there's no way it's the Chinese or the
Russians or anyone else's technology
that should
that should arrest our attention you
know collectively to to a degree that
nothing in our lifetime has and now one
worries that we're so
jaded and confused and distracted that
it's gonna it'll get much less coverage
than than uh you know Obama's tan suit
did you know a bunch of years ago it's
just it's uh
who knows how we'll respond to that but
it's just to say that
are the need for us to tell ourselves a
a an honest story about what's going on
and what's likely to happen next is
never going to go away right and and
it's important it's just the the the
division between me and every person
who's defending traditional religion is
where where is it that where is it that
you want to lie to yourself
or lie to your kids like where is
honesty a liability and I and for me
it you know I I've yet to find the place
where it is and it's so obviously
a strength
in almost every other circumstance
because
it is the thing that allows you to
course correct it is the thing that'll
that allows you to hope at least
that your beliefs that your stories are
in some kind of calibration with what's
actually going on in the world yes it is
a little bit sad to imagine that
if aliens on mass showed up to Earth
that would be too preoccupied with
political bickering or to like these
like fake news and all that kind of
stuff to notice yeah the very basic uh
evidence of reality I I do have
a glimmer of hope that there seems to be
more and more hunger for authenticity
and I feel like that opens the door
for a hunger for what is real
like that people don't want story like
they don't want like layers and layers
of of uh like fakeness uh and I'm hoping
that means
that will directly lead to a greater
hunger for reality and reason and truth
you know truth isn't dogmatism like
truth isn't uh authority of a PhD and
therefore I'm right uh truth is almost
the
like the the reality is there's so many
questions there's so many Mysteries
there's so much uncertainty this is our
best available like a best guess and we
have a lot of evidence that supports
that guess but it could be so many other
things and like just even conveying that
I think there's a hunger for that in the
world to hear that from scientists less
dogmatism and more just like this is
this is what we know we're doing our
best given the uncertainty given I mean
this is true with uh obviously with the
virology and all those kinds of things
because everything is happening so fast
there's a lot of and biology is super
messy so it's very hard to know stuff
for sure so just being open and unreal
about that I think I'm hoping will
change people's hunger and openness and
Trust of uh what's real yeah well so
much of this is probabilistic it's so
much of what can seem dogmatic
scientifically is just you're just
you're placing a bet on
whether it's worth
reading that paper or rethinking your
presuppositions on that point you know
it's like it's not it's not a
fundamental closure to data it's just
that there's so much data on one side or
so or so much so much would have to
change in terms of your understanding of
what you think you understand about the
nature of the world if this new fact
were so that
you can pretty quickly say all right
that's probably [ __ ] right like and
it can sound like a fundamental closure
to new conversations new evidence new
new data new argument but it's really
not it's just it really is just triaging
your attention it's just like like okay
you're telling me that uh
your best friend can actually read minds
okay well
that's interesting
let me know when that person has gone
into a lab and actually proven it right
like I don't need like this this is not
the place where I need to spend the rest
of my day figuring out if your buddy can
can read my mind right
but there's a way to communicate that I
think I think it does too often sound
like you're completely closed off to
ideas as opposed to saying like this is
you know as opposed to saying that
there's there's a lot of evidence and
support of this
but you're still open-minded to other
ideas like there's a way to communicate
that it's not necessarily even with
words it's like
it's even that Joe Rogan energy of it's
entirely possible just it's that energy
of being open-minded and curious like
kids are like this is our best
understanding but you still are curious
I'm not saying allocate time to
exploring all those things but still
leaving the door open and there's a way
to communicate that I think that that
that that people really hunger
uh four